feminism is the idea that men and women
are identical and indiscernible for all
practical purposes rather than
complementary which was the traditional
understanding of sexual difference I
have to reject a couple of your premises
one that college students work hard and
study that was never my experience two
that college is an unpleasant experience
I found it to be very fun and three that
women were these ignorant docile
uneducated creatures unintelligent and
and basically worthless before feminism
I I think that's so absurd it's
obviously very offensive but it just
isn't true I think women were much
better educated before feminism